عشاق القراءه والكتب كثر وقد تكون انت
واحدا منهم لكن ماذا لو وقع بين يديك كتاب
ثم عرفت ان غلافه مصنوع من جلد بشري وماذا
لو علمت من هو صاحب هذا الغلاف
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هذا الكتاب يحمل عنوان اقدار الروح وموجود
حاليا في مكتبه جامعه هارفارد كتاب قديم
يبدو كغيره من الكتب الاثريه لكن حقيقه
صادمه تكمن في تفاصيله وهي ان غلافه مصنوع
من جلد بشري يعتقد العامدون في جامعه
هارفارد ان الكتاب الذي يعود بمنتصف
الثمانينيات من القرن التاسع عشر مغلف
بجلد امراه مريضه مجهوله هويه ماتت لاسباب
طبيعيه وان الطبيب لودوف هو من صنع غلافه
تلك الممارسه الغريبه انتشرت في القرن
التاسع عشر رغم انها تعود في بعض الحالات
المكتشفه الى ما قبل ذلك بكثير
في متحف امشد في بريستول في بريطانيا يوجد
كتاب اخر من هذا النوع لكنه اكثر ترويعا
فغلافه مصنوع من جلد اول رجل اعظم في سجن
بريستون ويدعى جون هورود الذي اعدم في عمر
18 عاما بعد ادانته بجريمه قتل امراه عام
1821 وبعد محاكمه هورود واعدامه قام
الجراح ريتشارد سميث بتشريح جثته في
محاضره عامه في مستشفى بريستو الملكي ثم
قرر سميث ان يقوم بدبغ جزء من جلد هوربود
لتغليف مجموعه من الوثائق الخاصه بقضيته
وزخرف الغلاف بجمجمه وعظام متقاطعه مع
اضافه عباره جلد جون هورهوت الحقيقي
باللغه اللاتينيه
اما موضوع الكتاب فيتناول تفاصيل الجريمه
والاكثر غرابه ان هذا الكتاب هو الاكثر
شعبيه بين زوار متحف امشد في بريستول
اعتقد انها قصه حزينه للغايه يبدو ان
جونيور وورد كان شخصا ضعيفا وقد ساهم هذا
في تصرفاته تغليف كتاب جلد بشري مروع
بالفعل ويصعب فهم الاسباب وراء القيام
بذلك ان الامر يبدو انتقاميا بالنسبه لي
كتاب اخر يوجد في متحف كليه الجراحين
الملكيه في ادنبره صنع من جلد قاتل يدعى
ويليامبورج اعدم عام
1829 وهو عباره عن كتاب جيب صغير بني
اللون خاون من الصفحات الورقيه وكان
يستخدم لحفظ الملاحظات والنقود
تقارير افادت بانه كانت هناك عمليه
التشريحا علنيه وان بعض الجلد اختفى ثم
عرض هذا الكتاب لاحقا في ديمبرا ان اصدار
هذا الكتاب اتبع توجها كان يعتبر اجزاء
اجساد المجرمين نوعا من التعويذه
اما هنا في المكتبه الاكاديميه الوطنيه في
كازاخستان فتوجد مخطوطه يعود تاريخها لعام
وغلافها مصنوع من جلد البشر
المخطوطه مكتوبه باللغه اللاتينيه القديمه
ومكونه من 300 صفحه وتعود لكاتب عدل يدعى
بيتروس بواردوس من شمال ايطاليا لكن
الغريب في الامر انه قرئ منها عشر صفحات
فقط وتضم معلومات حول حسابات المدخلات
والمخرجات والائتمان والرهون العقاريه اما
باقي الكتاب فلا يزال محتواه تمثل لوكسا
[موسيقى]